[Music]
no none of you have seen this pablo
francisco i have not that i feel like
negrita tomorrow
okay fine pablo francisco
so do you want to set this one up yeah
uh sure so
everyone remembers or most of you
probably remember pablo francisco he was
this comedian movie trailer voice guy
little tortilla boy
um
he
had two specials he was like probably
what was it what would you say like
mid-2000s 2005
that's about the right play but yeah 15
years ago
sweet spot that sweet spot where like
people were downloading comedy specials
off like limewire and kazan [ __ ] like
that year
um that's because that's what kind of
got him big uh 2004
yes so
so
he got known for doing his stanford
whatever whatever uh and then he just
kind of fizzled out um but people didn't
kind of realize that it it was because
he got
oh he got bad into drugs he's cool
really really bad um so this is a famous
clip that someone posted and i'm
actually really because you guys are all
you know
do a lot of stuff about comedians and
stuff um
he
allegedly in this he's coked out of his
mind goes into like a
mental loop
and just i can't like that so it's one
of the most cringiest most epic things
i've watched but you guys that's all i
can really i want to spoil it
um so it's oh let me just set it up so
it starts off he's asked someone to come
on stage and do a bit with him
uh where they both do voices and that's
kind of where it's starting off
ready you'll know which one's pablo the
fastest
let's do arnold schwarzenegger arnold
schwarzenegger having sex with uh with
with arnold schwarzenegger sex with
gilbert god for you arnold
schwarzenegger
all right okay here we go all right
all right arnold schwarzenegger leaving
with gilbert godfrey gilbert crawford
are you seeing schwarzenegger right no
[ __ ] can somebody give me a [ __ ]
drink please oh he is coked oh boy
i have been around people birch that
have been really cooked up like smash
and um i know exactly what this is
you're right dutch um
very aware joe coletta what it's like to
be around people
that uh
hooter and greenway um i'm i'm i'm
sensing a pattern here royce
there's a lot of drugs
did footer also do anything
no voter had a band yeah
his biggest claim of fame was knowing
fred durst
i know fred durst
we need to somehow pull up the footer
like some sort of audio footage so we
can actually prove that there is a merch
voice clone okay anyway pablo francis
problem is what he has out there it
doesn't have mercury
pablo francisco
she's laughing at me it's okay
can someone give me a drink please look
at this man i swear to god
no don't go don't worry don't put it
please don't stay here okay but
don't know i said stay here right now
let's go okay can i please get a drink
of water please
okay anybody there's water
keep drinking right now
you want your money back right now oh
hold on come on oh look they're booing
what's that sweetheart
you want your money back right
refund okay hold on you're not going to
have a refund right now you're going to
say right
hey steve come back up here steve come
up here real quick we're gonna have some
fun right now bro
and this next song goes out to me
bro he's like he's like what is it
what's wrong man you want your money
back oh no i'm gonna give you a show i
yeah no no we're good oh what drugs am i
on oh i'm on drugs no kck
[Laughter]
okay he's not going to [ __ ] leave
hold on you know what this feels like it
feels like
you're flipping through channels very
fast and like you know what i mean like
different shows are coming on no because
they're not connected
this feels like i'm having a
fever-induced dream where pablo
francisco yells at me
that's what this feels like i can't get
myself out of this all right
honestly somebody couldn't get this and
flip it
i i can't no i'm saying i can't imagine
that's a hard thing to do in a movie
maker right
i mean i guess i could
i could right right i can right
when you do it the box is gonna [ __ ]
look weird
you can try it
oh you're right the box will look weird
it'll [ __ ] everything up
yeah
i did it for one set of videos and uh
yeah i just started but now i'm not
gonna do anything because it's the whole
opinion in the answer i don't even
bother turn your [ __ ] neck yeah i get
it i just think that somebody in editing
software could have easily fixed this
you know what i mean well why youtube
should you know they have an algorithm
that can pick out what we're talking
about on trailers but they can't [ __ ]
flip this automatically
what's that do i have some faith over
there okay here we go
hold on he's not gonna [ __ ] leave
i like i like that [ __ ] juice right
there buddy okay
all right
[ __ ] right now
is this giving a flashback to a certain
mlr live event oh yeah which one
enough arnold schwarzenegger's back what
what either one or two
[Music]
talk about three all right
[Laughter]
the sad thing is that's the one i could
confirm there was wow this gentleman is
very jewish
look at this guy on the screen oh wow
this gentleman is aggressively jewish
that's like
fear levels yeah yeah
yeah there you go he's a tortilla boy
okay
so they're calling out their favorite i
imagine being a comedian you have to do
like your best [ __ ] is that true
the other guy on stage must feel like he
wants to kill himself because i know i
would huh
i would have taken the show over by now
if that's the host then even worse i'd
want to kill myself right
because i think we all would have sat
back and watched this he gets to leave
but you have to work there you know what
i mean
hey there you go tortilla boy would you
say
and he's just wearing like a hawaiian
shirt but adidas sweatpants
you want to go home though i want you to
stay right here right now oh
i found another angle it's only a minute
long but check the locker i found it is
it something
[Music]
okay i think this is the end where he
shuts it down okay but then then i'll
leave that to the end because i'm still
enjoying this
what i'm not going anywhere tortilla boy
tortilla boy summer summer
hey how long ago was this
2017.
five years ago oh yeah
[Music]
well i know he just had he had a new
youtube special he did because there's
some clips of something from a year ago
and it's him now
whoa
that's [ __ ]
are you turning off [ __ ] that's
[ __ ]
is it because i'm black
you just pulled out a block
i don't remember what brought on my you
want to turn me off
whoa
that's [ __ ] are you turning off
[ __ ] that's [ __ ]
is it because i'm black
his penis is so big you can [ __ ]
dance with it [ __ ] yeah
i said that
wow
he is [ __ ] gone
what's that ma'am
already said that already holy [ __ ]
because i'm black
okay
pablo francisco is on something not
crack cocaine he's not cocaine
jesus get it straight
bombing hard
he is bombing
what's that trying to hear that what's
that like another half an hour
and he's got like another half an hour
on stage
oh what a nightmare god no
what's that sir
strip plugs
okay
right
ain't leaving right now we'll sit right
here right steve that's right that's
right steve's gonna try to help me out
of this right now
guys he's not [ __ ] i'm gonna see him
right here right not meth it's cocaine
no one's gonna [ __ ] leave right
i want to say the animal there you go
[Music]
fine i'll do it
and now it's time for everyone to have a
segment
[Music]
cocaine ritalin
what do you mean drugs i'm not on drugs
you're on drugs tortillas this summer
this summer this summer
i'm not even on coke it's it's something
else
jj wouldn't know actually jj you think
it's coke and pills maybe like like it's
all ritalin or something else it's pills
he's pilled out yeah yeah because like
cokey would actually be funny or realize
that he was sucking and just walk away
i i i could work with the mixture idea
but yeah this is cocaine and maybe
something else yeah
i need some confidence right now
what's that sir
all right now we got some people on my
side right steve
right steve
are you ready
if you can't stand up on your own in any
discussion and you go for backup
i i don't i don't
but i really feel bad for this opener jj
like i really feel bad for this guy you
know what i mean
his career is done yeah before he even
got started
he's always going to be that guy that
got stuck on the stage with a coked up
[ __ ] [ __ ] well no that's not true
that but [ __ ] do you know who else
did that joe rogan he has the biggest
podcast in the world remember when he
was on stage screaming at carlos medici
yeah but that actually like
that was one of my favorite bro
go back and re-watch some of that stuff
if you ever have free time that is one
of the most fun arcs in the world yeah
his art down is so good carlos
yeah one of the top comments of this
video is this is what happens when you
shut pablo francisco down while
installing updates
oh great does anybody have a safety pin
i have to reset them
legend has it he's still performing the
set
leave right now it's pretty good
okay [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[Music]
what you need to do is dr phil dr phil
are you ready are you ready to [ __ ]
do this
but he's not even okay i get that he's
the voice guy but he's so [ __ ] up he's
not even setting up
the jokes he's just going into
in and out of different bits it's it's
like it's like i said like changing a
radio station
all right [ __ ] that [ __ ] i ain't leaving
right now right
yeah take over steve come on [ __ ]
oh god did you know that he used to tour
as the three amigos with freddy soto and
carlos mencia pablos pablo francisco
freddy soto
and
carlos mencia for a night of comedy
i am not
with not can you imagine going to that
show do you remember freddie soto of
course you know freddy's soto um
what's that sir
i suck
yes really
no i ain't leaving right now i'm just
getting right here what's that story
yeah
[Music]
sure they're asking him to share his
drugs harry
i didn't understand that joke can you
say it one more time
what's that
all right there we go
yeah there you go baby you can do it
no bubbles are thinking get out of this
what's that sweetheart
all right all right
or you can have or you can hang with
allstate are you good hands
all right [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i think i now have timed it to where
we're at i don't want to get that too
fast
boom all right here we go good job
brother there you go baby you can do it
though
get out of this i wanted to finish my
beer because i just want to finish my
beer
i like this one perspective more all
right
are you can hand or you could hang to
the whole state are you gonna have
all right we'll see you you couldn't
appreciate the other and the other angle
because are you ready are you ready are
you ready
are you ready
this is amazing i'm gonna start doing
that to disarm people that are messing
at me so good this is so good
right what's that sir did you ask him
bring the other guy up hey guys i got a
question
is he even wearing shoes
get ready no he's in socks
yeah he's not even wearing shoes oh [ __ ]
what's the guitar doing there does he
ever even pick it up
[Music]
and we've reached elmo the track pants
are so long that they're touching the
ground because he's not wearing shoes
yeah the craziest part is
i know i know i know
this summer arnold schwarzenegger's back
leave me alone you have to get out of
here he looks like he went blindfolded
into a tj maxx and like grabbed five
things and put them on just [ __ ]
randomly
down get down
okay no one likes me anymore
no
no hey pablo here's the thing i never
liked you
okay but but wait but the three amigos
papa freddy
shut the [ __ ] up
i'll start calling you bessie soto i
swear to god
i'm going to rather plot receive right
now how about a round of applause oh
steve oh god steve steve leave steve
leave steve leave steve leave at this
point you would not get in trouble
everybody would know you did nothing
wrong
but leave for i know this is old video
but i can't help it just wanting telling
steve to leave steve's probably a nice
guy you know
take over what's that so i don't let
steve take over
take over how about steve takes over
right [ __ ] now
this steve is uh steve kramer a fellow
impersonator with them okay so let steve
go wait what's his name
steve kramer
yeah okay then even more than steve
[ __ ] leave
steve is standing there like mike myers
next to kanye west after he said george
bush hates
hates black people
uh
oh i found yeah he does a lot of it
steve kramer i might not also i think i
might not like him either oh no well
it's possible but he can't be that bad
right no no no okay maybe he is i'm
gonna actually look at him before i
judge him i'm gonna look at him before i
join her let's give him a shot let's
finish this first
okay
is that right how about steve breaks
over man no man i ain't living right now
i'm staying right [ __ ] here
how about i leave how about you suck my
dinner right there
what's that sir
how about you
oh
how did he fall off stage
well the other guy didn't even touch him
it's hard to see
it's hard to see he didn't see where the
step was and he fell
uh
you just need to get up and walk out and
never okay
now royce we need to see that fall from
the other end oh this is so good this is
so
good
oh that's not it and it's probably where
the bump is
in the timeline
we're going to get hit again
because oh you're right you're right
okay there's the other angle i love that
we have angles this is so good okay
i'm staying right [ __ ] here
how about i leave how about you suck my
ding dong right there
what's that sir
how about you [ __ ] up
oh
eddie took steve with him
nothing touched him
dude he's just like his head just led
the way you felt like a woman that's a
weirdo hold on hold on that is a woman
fault hold on it is oh
he's off he's off a cliff i've seen my
wife trip
face first
timber wow
you know that was a uh a good set under
right he really knows how to close
that's a good closer i i will admit i
will admit
that's the best impression yet bro hold
on one more time
i'm sorry about that but he fell on
somebody does he recover let's see let's
see are you ready you ready we there's
two minutes left oh no we're staying
right here we're not getting off right
now
no one's getting stuck
back up this summer this summer this
summer
in a world in a world it's summer
falling into theaters
i'm okay i'm okay yes my head's bleeding
it's summer this summer his head is
bleeding his head is bleeding you're in
a world where your head is bleeding in a
world where cte is bad
no you see no bessie you [ __ ] he's a
very good impersonator he was doing his
kelsey grammer impression
see he wouldn't want me over if he
wanted you know went down they'd be like
18 naked cowboys in the shower
and started off into that but do you
remember when kelsey grammer fell off
the stage yes
it'll work
thank you very much steve here we go
what's that sure
come on give me some love right there
come on
all right here we go i like that [ __ ]
i ain't leaving up i swear to god i'm
not gonna leave right now
i'm gonna go viral
[Music]
oh
yes sir it is
save the video all right here's the cop
plus
for me right now how about we just do
this all over the world
okay right
right
all right no one's gonna hear that [ __ ]
okay support steve's just recovering
right now
eve look steve's just like hey
man like like pablo you really like like
just just end this and then he goes and
steve's here he goes in a world in the
world
in the world
no you're not gonna say this right now
let me tell you something right now
you're not gonna see this summer
how many people want to see me go on
right now
yes
first off who the [ __ ] is stupid enough
to leave here i wouldn't leave you know
i wouldn't leave and and secondly
of course i i want you to i wouldn't
fight forever
dude i wanted to keep doing this do he
falls
i want my five dollars worth yeah i'm
doing this yeah
yeah yelling i bet you can't fall off
all sides of the stage
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's because you're in good hands are
are you in good hands are you in good
hands do the voice do the voice pablo
do it one more time we got like a few
seconds left in a world
right now i can't get off stage right
now
come on steve you can do it babe
somebody ask steve if he wants to do our
show
somebody sent steve a message
steve there'll be more people here than
there was there i promise i
i promise you more people will see this
we need the inside baseball in a world
in a world in a world
i can't stop doing it now
get down
here
i apologize i take back everything i've
ever said about papa francisco he is
hilarious
okay hold on how many people right here
think i can get out of this right now
jack true what's that i don't
okay so his twitter is i am there's two
steve kramers but you want i am steve
kramer okay that is the right one okay
um and uh
he seems to like i mean all his thing is
stan the stan the stand-up comedian from
kansas does it all
so he's he's available
a jerk
chinese
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
i ain't gonna leave right now folks i'm
gonna stay right here
hey gave me my money
how many people right now
right now
how many people right now
the guy telling him you can't film you
can't film your camera he goes give me
my money back i can't do that then leave
me alone he has a very good point but he
did stop because that's where the video
ends
um i uh and then i just put in the
locker the little tortilla boy like the
actual him doing it in his prime
so you can actually hear what it's
supposed to sound like it's in a world
in a world
i'm really surprised i didn't see that
one though any topic regardless what it
is and make it cool
[Music]
you must fight to survive
he saw tortillas on the corner
i will not play any more of it
um
sorry but the only the only one i'm ever
the only papa francisco i'll ever
remember now is what i just saw yeah any
other pop of francisco doesn't mean
anything to me you start texting each
other in a world